[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo le meilleur de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec à mes
côtés marion baker bonjour avions
bonjour à vous auriez même en chimie
l'hommage de l'assemblée nationale aux
victimes des attentats n'a pas effacé
les polémiques dans l'hémicycle les
députés unanimes ont salué la mémoire d'
arnaud beltrame
mais les critiques de l'opposition ont
ressurgi la lutte contre le terrorisme
divise elle les écoles hors contrats
seront davantage encadrer la proposition
de loi centriste du sénat a été adopté
jeudi à l'assemblée et la réforme de la
sncf un nouveau front s'est ouvert pour
le gouvernement après les syndicats le
sénat propose sa réforme ferroviaire
pour protéger lé territoire et pour en
débattre nous accueillons aujourd'hui à
rémi féraud bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste est bienvenue à vous
et on va tout de suite commencé cette
semaine avec l'hommage
après les attentats hommage rattrapé par
les polémiques à l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mardi députés sénateurs ont rendu
hommage au colonel arnaud beltrame et
aux victimes de l'attentât de trèbes
une minute de silence a été respectée
dans les deux chambres avant les séances
de questions d'actualité au gouvernement
séance spéciale à l'assemblée durant
laquelle edouard philippe a répondu aux
différents groupes parlementaires sur ce
sujet mais la polémique s'est invitée
dans l'hémicycle et l'opposition de
droite ne s'est pas privé de critiquer
l'exécutif céline martel d'abord le
silence de l'hémicycle un hommage au
lieutenant colonel arnaud beltrame et
aux trois autres victimes des attaques
des 10 de l'aude puis chaque président
de groupe prend la parole jean luc
mélenchon évoque avec force le sacrifice
de ce gendarme mort après avoir pris la
place de personnes prises en otage il a
réaffirmé la primauté de la compassion
il a assumé la primauté d'un altruisme
absolu celui qui prend pour soi la mort
possible de l'autre à notre tour de
refuser à l'ennemi
quelques victoires que ce soit est
d'abord celle de la division de la
confusion et de la polémique qui
viendrait à nous déchirer moment rare
les députés de la majorité
l'applaudissait semaines les
interventions socialistes et communistes
sont sur cette même tonalité seul
discours dit ce nom celui de christian
jacob patron des républicains
c'est insupportable de penser qu'un
officier supérieur de la gendarmerie a
été poignardé par un homme surveillée
depuis 2014 fiché s radicaliser notoire
nous pensons que le temps est venu de
prendre de nouvelles décisions
l'enfermement ou le bracelet
géolocalisable pour les individus
français radicaliser et fichez
l'expulsion du territoire national pour
les individus étrangers radicaliser et
fichés enfin l'état d'urgence que vous
n'auriez pas dû lever et que nous vous
demandons de rétabli
dans son intervention le premier
ministre fustige ses début de polémique
ceux qui affirment que cet attentat
aurait dû être évitée ceux qui croient
pouvoir promettre aux français un risque
zéro
je le dis cela prenne dans leur légèreté
une bien lourde responsabilité un
discours salué par une assemblée de bout
à l'exception du groupe l'est
républicain et des députés du front
national rémy ferrand vient de voir un
cas politique a très vite repris ses
droits à l'assemblée cette séance de
questions d'actualité s'est finalement
déroulée dans un climat un peu
électrique est ce que l'opposition de
droite a eu la bonne attitude selon vous
non ils font des polémiques de la
surenchère souvent pour dire n'importe
quoi sur le fond sur des notions
juridiques essentiel d'ailleurs j'ai vu
que le des politiques de droite sont
venus le leur rappeler donc non ils
n'ont pas eu la bonne attitude j'ai
constaté d'ailleurs que c'était
différent au sénat où l'atmosphère est
n'était pas électrique où elle était la
gravité étaient très partagés et où les
questions des républicains ont été
beaucoup plus digne à y revenir
écoutez gérard larcher justement sur le
fond enfermement des fichiers est ce
bracelet électronique
expulsion des étrangers radicaliser
rétablissement de l'état d'urgence c'est
ainsi que l'on éradiquera le terrorisme
non c'est avec du sérieux de la
détermination de la continuité dans
l'action et il faut des débats
politiques il y en a eu sur la dernière
loi terrorisme mais sans surenchère
polémique pour des raisons on cède à
l'émotion et souvent on a des arrière
pensées dans la surenchère
hall a clairement et d'ailleurs j'ai vu
que suit surenchère de laurent wauquiez
de christian jacob sont aussi plusieurs
responsables politiques de droite y
compris
frédéric péchenard qui a été directeur
de la police auprès nicolas sarkozy qui
a dit ça ça ne va pas il ne faut pas à
cette histoire des fichiers s c'est un
outil de renseignement l'utiliser pour
enfermer emprisonner des gens on les met
en rétention d'abord ça n'est pas
possible légalement
et ensuite ce serait
détruire un outil de renseignement qui
doit rester un outil de renseignement
est ce qu'il y a des progrès à faire des
choses à changer
oui certainement chaque attentat permet
justement de faire un bilan et de voir
ce qu'il faut améliorer il faut pouvoir
le faire sereinement et sur ce sujet
alors que je me situe dans l'opposition
je suis fier que la gauche des
socialistes soit en soutien du
gouvernement lorsqu'il agit sérieusement
sur un domaine aussi essentiel vrai
qu'on voit malheureusement les attentats
se multiplier avec souvent le même
scénario
est ce que finalement à l'opposition n'a
t'elle pas raison de pointer les
défaillances et qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire pour améliorer les choses que vous
parler d'amélioration dans les attentats
ne se multiplient pas et les scénarios
ne sont pas toujours les mêmes
ce qui est impressionnant qu'il faut
saluer aussi notamment à part de nos
forces de police
renseignements c'est le nombre
d'attentats qui sont des jouets
et puis le premier stade il n'y a pas de
risque zéro il y aura d'autres attentats
et notre capacité de résilience c'est à
dire aussi notre capacité à vaincre le
terrorisme islamiste dans la durée cela
nécessite une unité nationale après
chaque attentat
et s'il y a des des erreurs qui ont été
faites ou des éléments à améliorer de
pouvoir le faire dans la sérénité dans
une certaine unité nationale
j'ai été maire du 10e arrondissement
pendant longtemps j'ai été confronté
directement aux attentats du 13 novembre
je sais à quel point françois hollande a
été un très grand président de la
république face au terrorisme
je vois que emmanuel macron veut
s'inscrire dans la continuité de
l'action qui a été menée il faut en
effet l'expression de latérite face au
terrorisme il a montré
l'autre jour lors de l'hommage national
une qu'il était vraiment à la hauteur de
cette situation c'est est ce qu'il va
s'exprimer rapidement sur ce sujet de la
lutte antiterroriste il doit prendre la
parole nous avons voté une loi au
parlement pour sortir de l'état
d'urgence justement en ayant des outils
juridiques d'ailleurs certains ont été
contestés par les députés sénateurs de
gauche mais la loi était adoptée à
l'automne je crois pas qu'il faille à
nouveau une nouvelle loi dans l'urgence
emmanuel macron a fait un discours qui
était un très beau et grandissent
pour l'autre jour lors de l'hommage
national je crois pas que va je n'ai pas
à dire s'il faut qu'il fasse un discours
tout de suite je souhaite que nous
prenions tous cette question avec le
sérieux et la gravité qu'il faut alors
on a parlé de l'assemblée même émotion
au sénat mais dans un climat beaucoup
moins électrique le président gérard
larcher a tenu à rendre lui aussi
hommage aux victimes de cet attentat de
très bons l'écoutent vendredi dernier
notre pays a été frappé une nouvelle
fois par de lâches attaques terroristes
à trèbes à carcassonne dans le
département de l'aude
le bilan est lourd quatre personnes
décédées plusieurs autres blessés
j'adresse au nom du sénat tout entier
mes pensées mes condoléances aux
familles des quatre disparus
il s'appelait jean mazières
christian medvès hervé sosna et arnaud
beltrame cet officier est mort en héros
en se livrant aux terroristes en échange
de la vie d'une femme
cet acte de courage d'abnégation de
fidélité à son serment doit rester dans
nos mémoires 1 rémi féraud le temps du
sénat népal même pas de place pour la
polémique au sénat je pense que peut
être instruit aussi de la séance à
l'assemblée nationale en tout cas je
vois que la droite sénatoriale s'est
comporté de manière plus digne et gérard
larcher le président du sénat rendu un
hommage qui nous a tous rassemblés
c'était c'était vraiment important et un
moment important
il faut aussi pouvoir être digne du
geste absolue du colonel beltrame qui
doit aussi nous inspirer dans notre
défense de la république et c'est dans
ce contexte pour lutter notamment contre
l'embrigadement islamistes que les
députés ont vanté ont voté le
renforcement
des écoles hors contrat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la proposition de loi centriste a été
adoptée jeudi à l'assemblée
ces écoles libres hors contrats seront
davantage contrôlés 40 % d'entre elles
sont des écoles confessionnelles et avec
cette loi le gouvernement espère éviter
les dérives idéologiques
alice rougerie cette proposition est
adoptée
monsieur le rapport une proposition de
loi pour mieux encadrer les
établissements rencontre a défendu tout
au long des débats par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale plus de fermeté
dit il pour lutter notamment contre le
phénomène de radicalisation il a été
très clair au cours de ces débats que
nous visons des phénomènes de société
qui sont dangereux pour notre pays
dangereux pour nos jeunes est ce que
c'est sûr là que nous visons pour mieux
encadrer cet enseignement sans lien avec
l'éducation nationale
il y aura un contrôle annuel de chaque
établissement sous l'égide du triptyque
maires préfets procureurs
le délai pour s'opposer à une ouverture
sera allongée à trois mois et les motifs
de fermeture seront étoffées il faut
évidemment pouvoir lutter de manière
efficace et faire en sorte que lorsque
des établissements privés hors contrat
se développent et bien un minimum de
contrôle puisse être effectué ceci pour
assurer on a eu l'occasion de le dire
évidemment la protection des des enfants
de de france quart des établissements
hors contrat il y en a de plus en plus
800 en 2010 1300 l'année dernière c'est
ce qui inquiète alexis corbière
notamment pour la france insoumise qui
n'a pas voté le projet de que pour
lutter contre ce phénomène inquiétant
avec sept mois nous avons désormais un
couteau sans lame dont même nous avons
perdu une manche au cours des débats
nous aurions dû sortir de ce simple
régime de déclaration pour ouvrir une
école pour passer un régime
d'autorisation afin qu'ils ne soient pas
plus facile comme ça a été dit d'ouvrir
un débit de boissons une école un
équilibre a au contraire été trouvé
entre contrôle et libertés répond le
ministre de l'éducation nationale les
mesures votées seront opérationnels dès
la rentrée prochaine
errance ce sujet que c'est une bonne
proposition de loi c'est une proposition
de loi nécessaire mais c'était une
proposition de loi insuffisante
il aurait fallu avoir des mesures plus
fermes qui permettent davantage
davantage de contrôles ceci dit et je
comprends les députés nouvelle gauche
qui l'ont voté cette proposition de loi
qui vient du sénat permet d'améliorer la
situation actuelle mais nous souhaitions
aller plus loin justement vous avez
entendu alexis corbière c'est un couteau
sans lame c'est un rendez vous manqué
cette loi il aurait fallu passer
notamment un régime d'autorisation de
ces écoles hors contrat je crois qu'il
aurait fallu passer un régime
d'autorisation préalable plutôt qu'une
simple déclaration même si les
possibilités de contrôles sont renforcés
il aurait fallu rendre possible
davantage de contrôles notamment
aléatoire de la part des autorités de
l'éducation nationale être plus ferme
sur le contenu pédagogique
il faut être très attentif aux valeurs
qui sont véhiculées dans ces
établissements hors contrat
c'est un nombre très faible aujourd'hui
d'élèves
mais ces établissements se développent
leur nombre augmente et nous devons être
vigilants je pense que c'est un peu une
occasion manquée et qu'il faudra y
revenir je suis persuadé que c'est une
étape en réalité parce que je ne
comprends d'ailleurs pas bien pourquoi
le gouvernement n'a pas voulu aller plus
loin j'en suis même un peu surpris un
rituel et contrairement à ce que dit
jean michel blanquer
selon vous non c'est un équilibre c'est
mieux que la situation actuelle mais
c'est insuffisant et nous avions
d'ailleurs au sénat les sénateurs
socialistes voté contre en première
lecture pour bien montrer que nous
voulons aller plus loin avec cette
question des fichiers est ce qui
finalement pour ouvrir un établissement
des députés avaient notamment proposé un
amendement pour leur interdire cette
possibilité d'enseigner d'ouvrir ce type
d'établissement là le gouvernement
aurait dû être plus vigilant il le
gouvernement a répondu
on a sept cet amendement en disant ça
rentrera dans les motifs d'ordre public
je pense qu'il ya un certain flou et
qu'il y a en effet des garde-fous qui
n'ont pas été mis dans cette dans cette
loi voilà pourquoi je pense qu'il faudra
y revenir aussi l'école doit être un
lieu prioritaire dans la lutte contre la
radicalisation tout à fait parce que
c'est le lieu où doivent se transmettre
les valeurs de la république à tous les
enfants dans tous les quartiers
quelles que soient leurs familles
donc bien sûr que l'école a un rôle
extrêmement important à jouer dans la
lutte contre la radicalisation dans le
la transmission des valeurs
républicaines et ses écoles hors
contrats qui sont extrêmement diverses 1
dans l'eure dans leur nature il faut que
nous y soyons vigilants et cette
proposition de loi ne met pas tous les
garde-fous vous entendez ses détracteurs
à cette proposition de loi qui prône
tout de même la liberté d'enseignement
qui a été acté en france mais la liberté
d'enseignement n'est pas remise en cause
mais la liberté d'enseignement ne doit
pas empêcher le contrôle de la qualité
de l'enseignement et des valeurs qui
sont véhiculées on va passer à
l'actualité du sénat rémi féraud puisque
cette semaine la haute assemblée s'est
penché sur la réforme ferroviaire
[Musique]
le sénat a examiné son propre texte sur
l'ouverture du rail à la concurrence une
manière pour les sénateurs de contourner
les ordonnances et d'imposer un débat
sur ce sujet quand un calme et à la
veille d'un immense mouvement de grève
des cheminots le débat au sénat sur la
concurrence du ferroviaire s'annonçait
particulièrement d'actualité
depuis des semaines le gouvernement
disait vouloir légiférer à grande
vitesse ce texte voulu par les sénateurs
auraient donc pu porter la réforme
mais rebondissement au début du mois le
gouvernement annonce l'utilisation des
ordonnances
une décision dénoncée avec force dès les
premières minutes de l'examen dans
l'hémicycle comment ne pas y voir un
mépris absolu du travail du sénat du
parlement dans son ensemble et au delà
de nos compatriotes car sur un tel sujet
un vrai débat s'impose
et pourtant entre le texte des sénateurs
est ce que l'on sait des ordonnances du
gouvernement il y a la même volonté
concernant cette ouverture à la
concurrence de la sncf
avec pour les lignes régionales la
possibilité pour les régions de lancer
des appels d'offres mais en rendant
obligatoire le transfert des personnels
ses salariés conserveraient alors leurs
avantages sociaux et salariaux
concernant les lignes tgv
là encore le texte crée de fortes
contraintes pour le nouvel opérateur qui
reprendrait une ligne rentable ils
seraient obligés de desservir les
tronçons déficitaire de la ligne dans
l'hémicycle la forte opposition est
venue du groupe communiste qui
s'opposent aux principaux articles de la
loi
selon eux le texte met un pied dans
l'engrenage de la fin du statut de
cheminot
toutes ces dispositions sont
scandaleuses et poursuivre au fond le
plan social engagé là et ce siècle qui a
vu le nombre d'emplois publics diminuer
constamment depuis des décennies un
débat en forme de tour de chauffe avec
peu de détails sur ce que le
gouvernement entend proposer dans ses
ordonnances
le texte du gouvernement est prévue dès
le mois d'avril au parlement m us héros
justement pourquoi une telle proposition
de loi avant celle du gouvernement c'est
une façon de dénoncer les ordonnances
proposition de loi elle vient de la
droite sénatoriale de la gauche du
groupe centriste
elle a au moins un mérite en effet ces
deux d'obliger le gouvernement qui
d'ailleurs s'ils refusent absolument a
parlé sur le fond
et alors qu'il veut passer par
ordonnance est évacué le débat de fond
c'est le mérite de cette proposition de
loi ont par ailleurs je ne partage pas
l'ensemble évidemment des articles des
attendus une aime l'esprit la
proposition de loi rappelle un certain
nombre d'éléments sur la protection des
petites lignes dans les territoires
ruraux
mais pour le reste elle s'inscrit dans
le même esprit très libérale que celui
du gouvernement
mais au moins on en parle dans la
tribune du sénat plutôt que cacher sous
le tapis
sur le fond du texte c'est vrai qu'il ya
très peu de différence entre ce que l'on
sait du projet du gouvernement et le
contenu de cette proposition de loi
qu'allez vous votre position sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence mais
l'ouverture à la concurrence elle est
prévue donc elle doit pouvoir se faire
mais elle doit pouvoir être encadrés et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement dit que pour
l'ouverture à la concurrence
il faudrait supprimer le statut des
cheminots ce qui n'est pas vrai sans
parler du problème tout à fait essentiel
qui est celui de la dette de la sncf ou
plutôt de sncf raison et puis de
l'investissement nécessaire dans le
secteur ferroviaire de la vie de sa
vision du service public de
l'organisation du territoire et en
passant par des ordonnances il y a de
quoi être inquiet parce que il ya
forcément des éléments qui nous sont
cachés dans les intentions du
gouvernement aujourd'hui vous pensez que
le gouvernement ne joue pas franc jeu
sur cette réforme de la santé a
clairement il ne joue pas franc jeu avec
les parlementaires
visiblement pas avec les organisations
syndicales le mouvement social qui
commence juste à la fin de ce week-end
risque d'être très suivie d'avoir de
lourdes conséquences et le gouvernement
a beaucoup de négociations mais en
réalité il ya très peu de négociation le
gouvernement a déjà renvoyé cette
question des petites lignes aux régions
il est revenu également sur cette
question de privatisation assurant qu'il
n'y aurait pas de privatisation de la
sncf ne vous rassure pas voyage leur
projet prévoit un changement de statut
de la sncf qui peut amener cette
inquiétude
il ya ensuite eu le rapport spinetta qui
était très dur sur les petites lignes
gouvernement est revenu dessus en
apparence nous n'en savons rien
est ce que cette question des petites
lignes était un leurre pour pouvoir
revenir dessus il ya une méthode qui ne
va pas et c'est désormais l'heure de
retrouver notre partenaire politique du
figaro.fr est jim carrey ses bons jours
vous nous avez rejoint pour cette
interview politique
bonjour rémi féraud on va parler un peu
du ps les militants étaient appelés
jeudi soir a confirmé définitivement
olivier faure à la tête du parti est ce
que c'est le bon patron pour redresser
un parti en difficulté
je crois je les ai soutenus je pense
qu'il a su montrer sa capacité à
rassembler les socialistes à se situer
au coeur du ps est aujourd'hui tout
commence pour lui donc je pense que nous
ouvrons une nouvelle phase tout commence
mais ça va être difficile
on a vu olivier faur la semaine dernière
il ya quelques jours dans les cortèges
syndicaux antilles sncf se faire siffler
le ps n'est plus en odeur de sainteté
justement dans ce type de courtage c'est
un problème bien sûr que ce sera
difficile mais ça c'est pas le principal
problème y compris quand le ps était en
bonne santé
électorales iraient toujours ok ne
trouvait pas assez à gauche et qui nous
siffler dans les cortèges nous sortons
de cinq années de responsabilité
gouvernementale
moi j'étais heureux qu'olivier fort et
de nombreux socialistes participent à
ces manifestations
et nous allons continuer lorsque nous
pensons que notre présence est
nécessaire et je crois que ça va être le
cas parce qu'il y avait à la fois
beaucoup d'injustice sociale
et puis très peu de prise en compte des
services publics aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement au delà
ceci dit dans notre participation aux
manifestations
il faut qu olivier faur engage un
travail du parti socialiste pour
reconstruire un projet et je sais que
c'est sa volonté sur la question de la
ligne justement il ya eu un autre coup
dur c'est le départ d'une partie de la
direction du mjs vers le mouvement
génération de benoît hamon c'est une
scission historique moissac ps au moins
ça clarifie les choses
il était un certain nombre à être molle
non enfin viennent venait de se faire
hier à tête du moins des jeunes
socialistes alors qu'ils étaient déjà
passés en réalité à génération le parti
socialiste a besoin d'un mouvement de
jeunesse qui soit peut être autonome et
j'ai été au moins des jeunes socialistes
ya quelques il ya quelques années mais
qu'ils soient proches et solidaires et
qui travaille avec le parti socialiste
donc ça clarifie les choses
par ailleurs comme une ancienne
présidente du mjs est parti avec des
mots très maladroit qui montre une forme
d'arrogance de mépris en l'occurrence
pour les nausées mais voilà je pense que
d'ailleurs cet esprit d'arrogance c'est
ce qui doit absolument quitter le parti
socialiste donc va chacun fait ses choix
bon vent alors vous êtes socialiste vous
êtes et guy également président du
groupe ps au conseil de paris anne
hidalgo a annoncé qu'elle voulait porter
une candidature de coalition aux
prochaines municipales mais on voit que
la république on march pousse ses pions
castaner qui a dit cette semaine qu'ils
avaient un besoin d'alternance à paris
et alors tout en laissant la porte
ouverte à anne hidalgo si jamais elle
voulait rejoindre ce projet d'alternance
c'est une hypothèse qui n'est pas très
crédible quand même je crois que marche
ils ne savent plus bien où ils en sont
dans cette préparation des municipales
anne hidalgo je le souhaite en tout cas
sera candidate elle aura son bilan et
elle aura un projet et elle rassemblera
celles et ceux qui sont progressistes
qui partagent nos valeurs et qui
partageront son projet ensuite j'entends
gouvernement chez les ministres qui sont
en charge en responsabilité sur des
dossiers très importants je pense par
exemple à nicolas hulot qui a encore
fière a dit que anne hidalgo était une
mère qui préférait la pédagogie à la
démagogie des ministres comme françoise
nyssen l'autre jour accompagne
approuvent l'action que mène anne
hidalgo et son équipe à paris ajoutée
pour assurer que sa politique avait été
un peu brutal sur la piétonnisation des
quais qu'il y avait eu un problème de
méthode
les avis sont partagés quand les autres
sont ceux qui ne sont pas en
responsabilité justement sur des sujets
de fond c'est-à-dire réalité christophe
castaner comme président du parti et
puis le porte parole du gouvernement
benjamin griveaux oui mais tout cela
et bien droit mais c'est très politicien
et les municipales sont dans assez
longtemps donc avec anne hidalgo nous
allons continuer notre coalition dont
elle parle vous souhaitez aller
grosso modo de la majorité actuelle qui
va jusqu aux communistes écologistes
jusque en marche
nous ne refuserons personnes qui
partagent à la fois les valeurs vosges
et le projet radical elle refuse
justement de d'envisager une alliance
avec en marche mais vous savez
aujourd'hui dans la majorité municipale
actuelle issue des listes de 2014 il ya
des socialistes des communistes des
verts des socialistes qui sont passés en
marche
et puis il y à des personnes je pense
qu'ils venaient du modem qui venait
comme dominique versini qui avait été
proche de jacques chirac nous sommes
déjà une majorité de large rassemblement
c'est nécessaire d'ailleurs pour gérer
et conduire une ville comme paris donc
ce sera tout à fait l'esprit aussi de
l'équipe que proposera pour 2020 anne
hidalgo
merci merci merci rémi féraud d'avoir
été notre invité cette semaine et nous
marions se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo
[Musique]